I have to ask you about
what was the catalyst,
'cause you do have a child.
That was the catalyst, like really.
It was like,
how do I live with myself
knowing that I am the example for this young person
if I can't speak up for myself and for other people,
especially in a time such as this that we are living in,
when these things are getting pushed to the surface
and now is the time for truth and healing
and having those hard conversations,
and if I run away from this now,
what do I tell my child?
You know, be that person.
If you have the platform and the privilege
to help other people,
dear God, use it.
And I just felt I just had to do it.
And I feel there should be exceptions
to the statute of limitations
because we're all sitting here going,
"How do these people get away with it for so long?
How are there so many victims?
Why can't anything be done?"
And it's because they've run out of time.
And you know,
I am, for the past couple weeks,
been running around talking about this,
promoting the documentary,
but last night,
I did get home and break,
because I've been running around having to be so strong
and clear and concise.
And you're sitting there,
you've got all this pressure.
You're the spokesperson for not just this documentary,
but for all domestic violence survivors,
and you're going, "Oh God, did I say it right?
Did I word it right?
What am I gonna get sued for?"
Like, how is this gonna come back to hurt me?
And then I stopped and thought
I should not be this scared to tell the truth.
And so the system is working,
but not the right system. (chuckles)
And we've gotta find a balance
to leave room for reform
but also give survivors this cushion that they need,
especially when we know so much more about trauma now
and how long it takes to process.
Do you wanna take the Phoenix Act beyond California?
Absolutely, and I feel like
this will be a part of my life forever,
and some people don't understand that,
they think, "God, don't you wanna move on?
Don't you wanna just stop
and just never think about this again?"
But it's like, by healing others,
you also heal yourself,
and it gives the pain a purpose.
And if I can turn this into a healing moment
and a moment for education and prevention
and to shine some light on this issue
that is severely under-reported and understood,
then that brings me happiness,
that brings me healing as well.
I think that your documentary is such a game-changer
for the reasons of helping people realize
that trauma does take a long time to realize,
for going out there and fighting
and changing the legal system.
I mean, I just have to say that
I think what I've learned about you
is that you might be one of the best mothers
I've ever seen in my life.
(Evan gasps)
How you take everything
that you've learned from your parents,
how you've managed to heal with them,
continue to work with them,
see human beings for who they are,
I have so much admiration for you.
You are the living example
of how a human being can function in this world.
Process, protect others, tell their truth,
you are my new hero.
Oh my God.
I'm so honored that you would share
in this experience for everybody,
and you will change the world,
and you will save lives from it.
You really will.
That's the goal, that's the goal.
(audience claps)
That is the goal.
There is, (chuckles)
(audience cheers)
thanks.
There's often a misconception
with survivors of abuse
that we are angry and just always out for revenge,
and no,
I really, really wanna approach this
from a place of healing,
and really, that is what we want.
We want healing and accountability,
and that's what we're asking for,
and safety, (chuckles) you know?
I think you're the fiercest!
Things that aren't too much
to ask.
(audience claps)
And you do, there's a levity to it.
Thank you, Evan Rachel Wood.
For more information about the statute of limitations
for domestic violence in your state,
please go to the TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com,
and you can watch the two-part HBO documentary film
"Phoenix Rising," which is now on HBO and HBO Max.
You are incredible, I'm so honored to do this with you,
thank you.
(bright music)
♪ Oh, oh ♪